was a new mobile app that was created in
England this is absolutely true it's
called tinder for cows yes yeah
that's right this is this is what it's
described it in the paper it's called
tut ER and it was designed to help
farmers this is real we didn't make this
up it's called tutturu it was designed
to help farmers find breeding matches
for their cows
it's fascinating we looked into it take
a look at some of the cow dating
profiles we found Barbara looking for
casual no-strings-attached milking
there's there's Shane no heifers there
is Hayley I won't lie down on the first
date unless it's going to rain Becky and
Taylor fun-loving couple looking for a
third Mildred DTF
there's Daphne work hard Moo heart no
kids the calf is my nephew
there's Madison you don't have to be a
Hindu to adore all this
settle down there's Kyle castrated but
still down to Netflix and there's
patricia hosting in the streets guernsey
in the sheets
there's Tracy I only date black cows
there's Sarah single ready to mingle
stuck in a fence and finally Geary sup
[Applause]